Tom Cruise's absence from the 2023 Oscars
drew a few jokes from host Jimmy Kimmel.
But, really, why wasn't he there considering
all those nominations for "Top Gun: Maverick"?
Did something upset him, or were there other
reasons?
"Top Gun: Maverick" soared into the Oscars
with six nominations, but star Tom Cruise
wasn't in attendance to see how well the film
fared on the biggest night of the year for movies.
Deadline was the first to confirm that Cruise
would not be attending the 95th Academy Awards
because his commitments to his craft and career
forced him to miss the prestigious affair.
Specifically, he was filming in Sicily and
the United Kingdom, completing his work on
"Mission: Impossible – Dead Reckoning Part
Two," the follow-up to the first "Dead Reckoning"
installment set to release in summer 2023.
There are high hopes attached to "Dead Reckoning
Part One."
Many hope it will have the same effect on
the box office that "Top: Gun Maverick" had
when it grossed over $1 billion in 2022.
"Maverick" not only proved to be the biggest
box office draw of the year, but it also earned
high-flying scores on Rotten Tomatoes.
On the Oscars red carpet, Cruise's "Maverick"
co-star Charles Parnell said that Cruise was
"And saving the movie industry while people
are frettin'."
"Maverick" was nominated for Best Picture,
as well as several other honors, namely, Best
Adapted Screenplay, Best Sound, Best Film
Editing, Best Original Song, and Best Visual Effects.
Cruise himself was nominated in the Best Picture
category as one of the film's producers.
"Maverick" didn't end up snagging that award,
but it did win for Best Sound.
While Tom Cruise is hard at work delivering
another big screen spectacle, Oscars host
Jimmy Kimmel couldn't help but point out how
the superstar skipped the ceremony.
During his opening monologue, Kimmel called
out the "Top Gun: Maverick" actor and "Avatar:
The Way of Water" director James Cameron for
not showing up to the year's biggest celebration
of cinema, despite being the two most vocal
supporters of the theatrical experience.
Kimmel quipped,
"The two guys who insisted we come to the
theater didn't come to the [Dolby Theatre]."
Kimmel then jokingly suggested that Cruise
disguised himself as actor Judd Hirsch wearing
one of those uncanny masks from "Mission:
Impossible."
Hirsch, nominated for Best Supporting Actor
for his role in "The Fablemans," laughed along.
The host wrapped up by pointing out Cruise's
athletic body in "Top Gun: Maverick" and tying
it into the actor's renowned faith in Scientology.
Kimmel said,
"Tom Cruise with his shirt off in that beach
football scene?
L. Ron Hubba Hubba!"
Cruise may not have been at the Oscars, but
Lady Gaga certainly was, delivering a mighty
and powerful rendition of her Oscar-nominated
track "Hold My Hand" from the "Maverick" soundtrack.
It was previously reported that Lady Gaga
would be skipping the event due to her commitments
to the "Joker" sequel "Joker: Folie à Deux."
Just hours before the 2023 Oscars began, Variety
confirmed that the pop sensation would take
the stage to sing "Hold My Hand."
Like the film, the song received significant
critical acclaim, with Variety calling it
an Oscar front-runner early on.
It was also well received by fans, especially
considering the music video has more than
155 million views on YouTube.
As far as honors go, the song has already
received some awards attention with a nomination
from the Grammy Awards for Best Song Written
for Media.
The "Top Gun: Maverick" soundtrack was also
nominated for Best Compilation Soundtrack
for Visual Media.
While it didn't win either of those accolades,
nor the Oscar for Best Original Song, Gaga's
stripped-down performance was an unforgettable
part of the Academy Awards telecast.
So even though Cruise couldn't make it to
the ceremony, "Top Gun: Maverick" was certainly
well represented at Hollywood's big night.